tonight I'm excited to announce that
PlayStation gamers will get their hands
on it first starting july seventeenth
and for those playstation fans who can't
wait until next month for the beta to
start we've got something extra special
for ps4 starting this thursday and
lasting through the weekend ps4 owners
around the world will get a chance to
play the destiny first look alpha visit
the website behind me he says hoping
it's there to be a part of the first
gameplay experience that it is only
available on ps4 but destiny isn't just
first on PlayStation it's better in
addition to all of the extra content
that only PlayStation customers will
receive i'm happy to announce our first
ever White PlayStation 4 that comes
with an exclusive destiny bundle that
will make available when the game
releases on sep tember 9th the bundle
includes a 500 gigabyte glacier white
ps4 a white jewel shop for the game and
a 30-day voucher for ps4 playstation
plus thank you to our friends at bungie
and activision destiny looks stunning on
ps4 and i know you're going to love
playing it on playstation destiny is
just the tip of the iceberg in looking
at all of the playstation 4 games that
will show tonight that are either
exclusive to ps4 look better feature
exclusive content or the ability to pay
it before any other platform let's now
take a look at another you like me